et on va parler de ça justement avec
notre invité Éric Coquerel bonjour
bonjour vous êtes député sortant de
Seine-Saint-Denis et je précise que vous
faites partie de ces candidats qui ont
eu plus de 50% des voix mais qui vont
devoir aller au second tour d'une partie
suffisante vous avez tiqué lors de la
présentation des résultats par Thibault
qui sont les résultats du ministère de
l'Intérieur Vous contestez le fait que
ensemble soit devant vous à 20000 voix à
peu près ben le contexte parce que c'est
contestable voilà c'est à dire que il y
a un espèce de tripatouage pour essayer
d'arranger les résultats en fait il y a
très simple il y a des candidats qui ne
sont pas comptabilisés dans la nuque
alors qu'ils sont soutenus par la nuque
depuis le début
Polignac est potier Dominique petit on
Meurthe-et-Moselle Hervé pardon Hervé
Solignac en Ardèche excusez-moi et puis
d'autres qui sont à l'inverse des
dissidents en marche et qui sont
comptabilisés dès le départ dans le
corps normal donc on fait des choses
d'un côté on ne fait pas de l'autre nous
on est pour nous à 26,8% des voix donc
on est devant
Dominique potier lui a pas voulu de
l'investiture de peut-être mais il est
soutenu par la nups et vous verrez que
si la nuit vous verrez qu'il siègera
dans un des groupes de l'anus donc c'est
encore une fois Monsieur Darmanin pas à
l'inverse fait des inclus des candidats
dans marche qui ne sont pas qui sont
tout ça c'est fait pour essayer
d'arranger les résultats le fait
ça les résultats quand vous êtes quand
vous comptez des choses à côté vous les
comptez pas de l'autre tout ça pour
finalement à 20000 voix après ça vous
permet de dire de commenter de
l'actualité en disant que ensemble est
en tête quand c'est l'anus qui est en
tête bah voilà c'est sans doute
tripatouage d'un rangement on va dire si
vous préférez à terme plus modéré bref
en tout cas c'est quelque chose qui ne
reflète pas la réalité parce que la
réalité excusez-moi c'est ça qui est
plus important ce matin c'est pour la
est-ce que vous allez porter un recours
officiellement
la comptabilisation des choses ça va pas
changer le résultat mais ça nous on
tient à le dire parce que non seulement
c'est un excellent résultat qui
transforme j'allais dire ce que l'essai
en réussite c'est lorsque nous avons le
faire avec l'anus mais j'allais dire
aussi c'est le plus mauvais résultat
d'un président de la République au
premier tour législatives voilà jamais
en prison il fait moins de 32% et ils
sont dans une grande difficulté parce
que non seulement nous pouvons être
majoritaire mais il y a quasiment une
chose à mon avis certaine c'est qu'ils
vont pas avoir de majorité de toute
façon donc il se retourne une situation
très complexe c'est une défaite de
premier tour pour Monsieur Macron et une
défaite encore plus grande du Premier
ministre qui je vous rappelle madame
borne et la chef de la majorité à mon
avis je vois mal comment elle va
poursuivre son travail mais juste si
elle remporté
donc si on est majoritaire il y a pas de
problème de façon Jean-Luc Mélenchon
sera Premier ministre mais si c'est pas
le cas
mal comment une chef de la majorité qui
prépare une élection pour une première
ministre sert à ça pour avoir une
majorité qui ne l'a pas je vois pas très
bien comment tout ça pourra se faire on
verra pas avoir une majorité même si
c'est pas pour vous s'il y en a pas une
majorité absolue elle ne pourra pas
poursuivre son travail
c'est une analyse politique que je fais
je vous disais dans tous les cas mon
avis madame born ne sera pas la première
ministre par la suite d'abord une chose
parce qu'elle échoue et deuxième chose
la manière un peu plus certaine parce
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon sera Premier
ministre vous dit que c'est un résultat
pour la nuit l'Union des gauches
pourtant quand on regarde le total de la
gauche en 2017 au premier tour c'est
quasiment la même chose que la nuque
aujourd'hui et le total des candidats
présidentielles de la nuque vous perdez
vous perdez du terrain
on vient de 2017 ou toutes les forces
qui aujourd'hui composent la nuque était
qualifiées dans 170 circonscriptions au
deuxième tour c'est ça la réalité
aujourd'hui en terme de dynamique où est
la dynamique aujourd'hui on part d'une
gauche divisée en 2017 qualifié dans 170
circonscriptions et avec un nombre
infiniment inférieur au nombre de
députés qu'elle aura cette fois-ci
aujourd'hui dans 406 circonscription
soit directement représenté par la Nupe
soit avec des alliés que nous soutenons
comme par exemple dans les dromes nous
sommes en capacité nous sommes au
deuxième tour un certain nombre
d’ailleurs ont déjà gagné 4 4 députés
ont déjà gagné alors que il y en a qu'un
seul du côté d'en marche et nous sommes
en capacité d'avoir la majorité donc je
trouve que par rapport à ce que nous
souhaitions c'est le retour d'une dans
ce pays capable d'être majoritaire c'est
une réussite mais est-ce que vous êtes
on va regarder on a regardé les
projections vous êtes loin de pouvoir
obtenir une majorité dimanche prochain
dans les projections oui mais dans la
réalité non parce que dans la réalité
nous sommes je vous le répète dans 406
circonscriptions nous avons une réserve
de voir ça effectivement par exemple 74%
des jeunes de moins de 34 ans se sont
abstenus si vous regardez le résultat de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon d'aller voter au
second tour on va faire notre boulot il
va falloir les convaincre continuer à
faire ce que nous avons fait nous avons
été sur le terrain souvent même les sols
on a eu parfois je peux vous le dire un
peu l'impression de boxer dans le vide
parce qu'il y avait pas beaucoup
d'autres forces en face de nous
notamment marche donc on va continuer et
puis j'espère peut-être que enfin ce
gouvernement va accepter des débats
démocratiques dans le cadre de la DR
semaine je pense par exemple on parlait
madame borne tout à l'heure elle est la
chef de la majorité il me paraît quand
même inconcevable dans la deuxième
partie de cette terre se met d'élection
n'y est pas à débat entre elles Monsieur
Mélenchon et les responsables des
principaux partis qui sont qualifiés
pour le deuxième tour
français on le doit aux Français on doit
au lieu que le gouvernement n'arrête pas
de mettre comme argument et Monsieur
Macron si c'est si c'est la Nupe c'est
le chaos c'est les chars soviétiques
enfin la nouvelle version de Charles
soviétique en 80 ça peut être efficace
cette tentative de diabolisation
est très mauvais parce que au moins vous
pouvez vous pouvez on peut discuter
ensemble du la hauteur de du bon niveau
de laquelle du résultat de la nuque par
contre on va s'accorder sur le mauvais
résultat d'en marche donc c'est ça pas
été une réussite et mais c'est surtout
par rapport au débat démocratique moi ça
ne me satisfait pas qu'une telle
abstention et pour qu'il n'y ait pas une
telle abstention peut-être pourrait-il
enfin que ces législatives soient ce
qu'elles sont s'il y a une élection
primordiale pour le pays parce que je le
rappelle si nous sommes majoritaire dans
une semaine nous appliquons notre
programme et ça change tout la majorité
présidentielle a indiqué donner des
consignes de Vogue au cas par cas dans
les 58 circonscriptions vous êtes en
duel avec le rassemblement national pas
une voix ne doit aller au rassemblement
national c'est ce qu'a encore dit ce
matin Olivier Grégoire est-ce que vous
souhaitez le soutien de la majorité
présidentielle dans ces circonscriptions
c'est à eux de voir ils ont madame
Grégoire a dit des choses différentes
d'hier soir ils étaient au cas par cas
apparemment elle explique ce soir ce
matin que c'est pas une voix pour le RS
que nous disons nous par ailleurs bon
voilà j'entends nous c'est ce que nous
avons dit d'ailleurs soir est-ce que
nous avions dit à la présidentielle mais
vous semble important mais des fois
alors
voter nuque c'est pas la même chose donc
oui oui vous êtes je suis bien vous
satisfaisait du pas une voix autant de
redire ça parce que je vous rappelle que
au soir du 1er tour des Présidentielles
tout d'un coup nous étions repas de
manière très très positive pour battre
Madame Le Pen puisque nous avions fait
nous avions lancé la consigne de pas une
voix pour Madame Le Pen ce qui valait
pas soutien monsieur Macron mais à une
chose dit clairement et là dans la
campagne on a eu l'impression que
véritablement nous étions des
adversaires de la public et autres à
nouveau de la même manière donc je suis
bien content d'entendre que il y a
peut-être une différence quand même pour
le gouvernement enfin j'attends qu'il
qu'il confirme les propos de même de
Grégoire ce qui hier soir ils étaient
pas très clair voici ce que vous
donnerez des consignes de vote dans les
circonscriptions vous êtes absents pas
une voix pour le rassemblement national
donc la même chose mais vous ne dites
pas il faut voter pour les candidats de
la majorité des conseils
parce que je vous assure que vu le bilan
du gouvernement tout autre est de
Monsieur Macron depuis 5 ans et vu la
politique qu'il annonce c'est-à-dire il
le dit à l'avance retraite à 65 ans on
va continuer à faire cette politique qui
avantage des dividendes les plus riches
on ne va continuer à ne pas bloquer les
prix etc il est impossible d'aller plus
loin quand Elisabeth borne appelle
toutes les forces républicaines à se
rassembler sur le projet de la majorité
sur les candidats de la majorité vous
vous sentez exclu de cet arc républicain
je pense qu'elle veut dire si c'est ce
qu'elle veut dire ça contredit justement
les propos de Madame Grégoire écoutez
franchement
estimé que on est républicain que si on
soutient un programme néolibéral c'est
quand même j'allais dire à côté
nos alternatif de même Thatcher c'est à
dire que l'idée qu'il n'y a qu'une seule
politique économique possible et qu'en
dehors de ça on est sur du champ et puis
non nous au contraire remettre la
République partout liberté égalité
fraternité et faire en sorte que à
nouveau par exemple dans toutes les
cités populaires les circonscriptions
populaires partout dans ce pays les gens
ont le droit au service public de la
santé de l'éducation de la sécurité qui
sont cassées les gens et le droit à
nouveau à des salaires convenables les
gens et le droit à nouveau à pouvoir
s'alimenter à pouvoir avoir de l'énergie
en bloquant les prix parce
qu'aujourd'hui la catastrophe est devant
nous vous savez j'ai entendu beaucoup
attention au chaos si c'est Monsieur
Mélenchon qui prémisse mais le chaos est
devant nous tient à dire on est en train
d'aller dans le mur et je ne vois qu'une
issue pour l'éviter c'est la politique
que nous proposons parce qu'il y a une
rupture franche avec ce que nous venons
de dire pendant 5 ans elle parlait pas
de l'économie elle parlait surtout de la
vision de la République elle a dit par
exemple hier soir la République ce n'est
pas la remise en cause de nos
institutions et le culte contre les
forces de l'ordre je comprends pas ce
qu'elle veut dire
si la République c'est d'estimé que
quand vous avez des policiers qui de sur
un contrôle de police tir est une
notamment une passagère de 21 ans qui ne
pouvait même rien d'être dans la voiture
et que on ne peut pas émettre la moindre
critique sur la façon dont on utilise
les forces de police moi je suis très
inquiet pour la République
quand on regarde les reports de voix
potentielles vous n'êtes pas forcément
en position de force par rapport à
ensemble mais vous avez potentiellement
des reproches je comprends pas ça quelle
est la force quelle est la force
politique du côté qui n'est pas
hors-ensemble et nuque qui appelle à
voter pour ensemble je ne connais pas
moi je vous parle des enquêtes d'opinion
réalisées auprès des électeurs et on
voit que en fait vous avez un petit
potentiel du côté des électeurs du
rassemblement national que leur
dites-vous aujourd'hui pense qu'on a un
potentiel vis-à-vis de tous ceux qui
n'ont pas envie de reprendre cinq ans de
Macron de plus voilà qui sont très
inquiets ils ont raison pour pour les
questions de jailidia d'accès au service
public dont j'ai parlé par exemple pour
une autre question monsieur Macron
annonce et gouvernement annonce qu'il va
falloir en 2027 est à 3% de déficit vous
savez combien ça fait ça fait 80
milliards à trouver et d'un autre côté
il nous explique qu'ils vont continuer à
baisser les impôts ou vont-ils les
trouver et qu'aujourd'hui ils peuvent
nous confirmer qu'il y aura pas
d'augmentation de la TVA par exemple
comme on l'a entendu dire tout ça tous
les Français qui sont inquiets par cette
politique aujourd'hui ils ont une autre
bulletin de vote c'est le bulletin de
votre nups donc il y a un référendum
anti Macron qui est en train de
s'installer pour le deuxième
[Musique]